Now, a crackdown against the LGBT+ community in Russia has intensified...
...after a tough new law was passed by the Russian Parliament.
The bill passed back in December places restrictions...
...on almost any mention of LGBT people or culture.
Here's Will Vernon.
When he leaves the house, Danya can't wear makeup.
But even then, he still feels afraid.
It's very frightening living somewhere where it's illegal to just be yourself.
I don't want to live in fear.
The 22 year old does something that can be very dangerous in Russia.
He's an openly gay drag queen.
But now, Danya plans to leave the country and move to France.
A new anti LGBT law has been passed by the Russian Parliament.
The main drag night Danya performs at has canceled its shows.
According to the law, it's forbidden to do what we do now.
I have to either leave the country...
...or stay here and wait for things to get even worse.
10 years ago, so-called gay propaganda was made illegal in relation to children.
But the new measures go much further.
Many are worried that even the slightest reference to LGBT culture...
...will now be banned.
Well, I've just bought this book recently published.
It's a gay love story, but if you look inside you can see that parts of it...
...have actually been redacted.
And shops right across Russia have been withdrawing other books from sale.
Books with gay references or characters in them...
...in case they get prosecuted under the new law.
It's almost as if LGBT people are being deleted from society.